now this week we're being warned not to
travel or in fact to go outside too much
because of the heat and lots of people i
know are going to be working out what to
do because a red warning has been
declared across england with a met
office warning of the possibility of
seeing temperatures of up to 40 degrees
on monday and tuesday well the heatwave
is bound to put some extra pressure on
the nhs and the ambulance services in
england are already at the highest alert
level because of extremely high demand
we can talk now to our next guest tracy
nichols the chief executive officer of
the college of paramedics thank you so
much for being with us
um
temperatures could hit 40 degrees this
week the new health secretaries ask
ambulance crews to work more hours on
monday and tuesday
what are we expecting to see
um i think sophie will we'll see uh the
normal demand that we're seeing sort of
running along currently which which your
viewers will be will be well versed with
but we could see uh people who are
particularly who are vulnerable young
people and elderly frail people people
living with dementia who
really do suffer this this isn't like a
lovely hot day where we can put a bit of
sunscreen on and go out and enjoy
you know a swim and a meal outside this
is serious heat uh that could actually
ultimately end in in people's death
because it is so ferocious and we're
just not set up for that sort of heat in
this country
what would your advice be to people who
are concerned about you know how to keep
themselves and their families safe and
not too hot over the next few days
without sounding patronising i think it
really is about taking sensible
precautions of course you know we love a
bit of warm weather but this is
something else so
try and stay in in the hottest part of
the day between about 11 and 4
because the heat is seeming to peak
later in the afternoon stay hydrated and
not with alcohol
really put sunscreen on even if you're
fully covered put sunscreen on wear a
hat and please check on those people who
are vulnerable and and that includes
people you know a homeless
community who who may just be transient
walking along the streets or or trying
to stay cool you know think about those
people people living with dementia may
not understand that sitting out in the
sun they may forget how long they've sat
out there for so really really pay
attention to
to vulnerable people during this time
and what contingency plans do the
ambulance trusts have
in place for the next few days so
obviously we know that this is a service
already under pressure and there could
be increased demand can't then
there are
sort of major incident plans if you like
but you know we're already running a
really stretched situation within the
ambulance sector but as uh the secretary
of state for uh health and social care
announced there is more money for call
handlers which will be
really welcome um i i don't know how
that money will translate into hours um
because it's it's quite late in the day
quite honestly but um it's really
welcome the ambulance sector will have
its contingency plans in place emergency
planning uh exercises are run regularly
within the ambulance sector so um the
the crews the uh call handlers and the
army of community first responders and
community teams will be out over the
next two days
um of course it comes at a time when
ambulance services are already under
serious pressure i just want to have a
look now at the waiting times for last
month so one in ten people waited two
hours for an ambulance and for serious
uh conditions category two things like
heart attacks like strokes the average
waiting time was over 50 minutes over 50
minutes for a heart attack i mean is
there a crisis
it's
it's difficult not to call it a crisis
sophie but it's it's been a stealth
crisis um and and i think you know
everyone who works in emergency care
knows that they will just put their
heads down and just keep plowing through
and keep dealing with whatever comes
through
the call handlers or through the
emergency department doors and they'll
just keep going
so it's not that people aren't going to
turn up it's just that the system
is is not enabling
paramedics um emergency department staff
to do exactly what they want to do which
is look after everybody
the west midlands ambulance director
mark dougherty gave an interview
recently where he said the 999 service
in his region would tip over in his
words in august when it might be
completely unable to respond to even the
most critical cases is this a serious
concern
it is this this will be based on
modeling that uh the ambulance services
do regularly and probably from mark's
perspective that is when his modelling
shows him that um maybe through covered
sickness absence maybe through annual
leave
through predicted demand that will put a
really enormous strain on on the west
midlands ambulance service um and and i
think what he's doing is sending the
flare up to say we don't do something
now um that you know that will realize
into something much more than a risk it
will be a reality
and i just want to work out what that
actually means as you say you know cover
cases are on the rise that has an impact
of course on absence too
does that basically mean that if you
call an ambulance and you need one you
might not get one
yeah and and i think we have to say that
for for many people who call for the
ambulance service it is absolutely
life-threatening and time-critical and
and is very much an emergency i think
where people may not get one is where
their
illness or injuries is less serious than
a heart attack or a stroke um and they
they may be told that an ambulance just
isn't available and people will have to
find their own way to to hospital that's
the that's the reality that we're in
central and what kind of cases are we
talking about is it you know broken legs
what's the what what kind of cases do
you mean
it may be something like abdominal pains
it may be
a headache uh where people are still
conscious it may be long-term problems
the ambulance service do get a lot of
long-term problems and that are called
through where someone's had back pain
for two to three weeks that can't be
resolved
so it'd be cause of much less serious
nature they'll be absolutely stringently
triaged by those superb clinicians in
the control rooms
and and people will they'll have that
discussion with them about a clinically
appropriate response
you concerned that at a time where we do
have this acute pressure on the nhs and
on ambulances in particular we've also
got a leadership contest going on and
we've got a government that of course is
still functioning but may not be pushing
through
any
new legislation or anything particularly
reforming
as there will be a change of prime
minister in september
i i think my my view and the view of the
college sophie is that um you know i
know the leadership contest is necessary
we really need to see leadership in
action now this crisis is now it was
yesterday it was the day before
yesterday it will be tomorrow so we need
someone to lean in and support this
whole system and do a shared clinical
risk and decision making process across
the whole system the ambulance service
is just the manifestation of a whole
system issue it's just a very visible
sign for the public
we've of course seen many of the
candidates talking about tax cuts and
the rise in national insurance that we
saw earlier this year was billed as a
health and social care levy and we know
that at least two of the candidates
wants to
reverse that are you concerned what it
might mean for funding for the nhs
i think so i mean in real terms we we
haven't really had a a vast amount of
funding um through the last 10 to 12
years um there was a deficit in the
workforce and
my goodness do we need good workforce
planning um to come out of
of this uh we've never been in a
pandemic before and there is this huge
backlog there is this huge demand for
services and we need to model through
that and then the transition into
whatever normal looks like after this
but but certainly that the funding is
absolutely critical and i think um
someone had called for ambulances and
ambulance services to be made critical
assets and i think that's that's
probably something for discussion
okay thank you so much really
interesting to talk to you and about
some of those pressures
on such an important service as well